in their Christian country. They kept
saying this is a Muslim area. No, this
is England.
>> Oh, Christian country. Interesting. This
is a Christian country where you've
abandoned your churches. You don't You
The only thing you do is get married and
bury your dead from there. Okay.
Anything to do with Christianity? No. Do
you read the Bible? No. Do you go to uh
church every Sunday? No. But it's a
Christian country. You know why? Cuz
Muslims are practicing their religion.
We're Christian now.
We are teaching people how to pray.
>> And every time they pray, you get the
share in that reward. And when they
teach their children And their
children's children the reward
continues. Every Fajr Zuhr Asr Maghrib
Isha Tarawih [music] Tahajjud Every
recitation you share in the reward. For
just £100
>> you can help teach 20 to 60 people
>> like me learn how to pray salah. Donate
today. Donate today. Donate today.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys are well,
inshallah. So, I came across a video of
a YouTuber called Asmongold. And uh he's
no good in any way, shape, or form. Uh
this intellectual [__] is reacting to
a video of a police officer being called
to some disturbance or some
uh issue altercation that's happening,
and he had to come and blame the
Muslims. Well, let's see what he's
blaming the Muslims for. And let's see
if the Muslims are wrong or right in
this specific aspect. Here's the video.
The policewoman standing up to the angry
mob of Muslims is a hero. The second
half of the video has gone viral after
this amazing policewoman put radical
Islamists in their place after they
called the police to remove a Christian
preach.
>> Okay, radical Islamists. So, they are
radical. Let's see what's radical about
them. They're radical Islamist jihadis.
Okay, let's see what's radical about
them. in their Christian country. They
kept saying this is a Muslim area. No,
this is England.
>> Oh, Christian country. Interesting. This
is a Christian country where you've
abandoned your churches. You don't You
The only thing you do is get married and
bury your dead from there. Okay.
Anything to do with Christianity? No. Do
you read the Bible? No. Do you go to uh
church every Sunday? No. But it's a
Christian country. You know why? Cuz
Muslims are practicing their religion.
We're Christian now. Context. teachings
about what what Muhammad taught.
And I'm quoting this.
And I'm asking them, do you believe
this?
Do you believe this?
I'm telling them that Christianity
preaches this.
Who's that preacher? Obviously in a
Muslim area.
Why do you come here and want us to
worship a Jewish man? We don't want to
worship a Jewish man. They want us to
worship a Jewish man. Okay, so obviously
firstly um
I mean the brother shouldn't be like
it's it's it's a bit petty Jewish man,
you know, in that matter. But is the
issue here that this man is just coming
there to preach about Christianity in
his own country? No.
No Muslim has issue at all. Christians
preach all day every day in Central
London where my table is when I talk
about Islam.
I have no problem Christians screaming
Jesus Jesus Jesus all day like. I don't
care about
this is their country and it's not even
matter of country cuz it's not
it's not Christian country with all due
respect. It's it's a liberal country.
But let's go with that. So is the issue
that the Muslims have there in
Whitechapel that he's just coming in
there preaching? Well, let's find out.
Listen, listen. I hear what you're
saying. In this country, we have freedom
of speech the same way you guys have
your freedom of speech. Now you guys
don't need to see eye to eye and you
don't need to agree and you're all more
than welcome to stand here and have
conversations with them.
>> no, some wrong girl is But they're not
being aggressive. I mean yeah, she's
bang on point. She's I mean she's
absolutely right. Couldn't say it
better, you know, at the end of the this
is a country of freedom of speech. Well,
they claim to be freedom of speech which
is absolute bull crap. But what she's
saying is very simple. You can preach
what you want to preach. He can preach
what he wants to preach. So if any of
those Muslims they have an issue with
that I think she's bang on point and
simple as that. Keep it moving. You
can't deal with it or whatever she's
saying etc. But is that the reality? Is
that what's really going on? Is that
preacher just come there just speaking
about Jesus and the gospel and how Jesus
died for the sins of the world? Well,
let's find out. Other than that she's
she's speaking sense.
Let me paraphrase what he just said.
Since the Christian preacher is in a
Muslim area, other Muslims could
eventually mess him up.
Okay, good. So let's see if that's true.
So, as I'm going to say, this guy is
lying because why would Muslims just
come and have an issue with somebody
preaching their religion? No, there's
something more to this. So, yes, he said
that, but that's only only to find out
what is actually going on. When we
really find out what is actually
happening, then things will fall into
perspective. That's very What are the
risks? The risks are that they could get
assaulted. All right. Isn't it? These
are just violent mobs of people that
want to beat the [__] out of anybody who
disagrees with their religion. The fact
that these people are in Britain in the
first place is a mistake. I don't know
who this little flipping [__] is. I
don't even know if he even has a a life,
uh, you know, or even has a a a life
with an a woman or a girlfriend. In
fact, he lives in his basement as far as
we know, under his mom's basement, uh,
and he's an absolute intellectual fraud.
Yes? So, what's that got to do anything?
Let's Let's find out what's really going
on. But when hundreds of people are
stopping him because what he's saying,
there must be something wrong, right?
If there's a lot of us that are mad,
that means that we're justified. Okay,
good. Again, it doesn't make point. Just
because there's a lot of you guys
standing there. Okay, let's let's go
with that, but but we're about to find
out what was really happening. There
must be something wrong, right?
So, why is he doing that? Yeah.
But you see, there's a difference
between hate and a freedom of speech.
Okay, good. So, now we're getting some
context. So, there's freedom of speech
and there's hate speech. Let's carry on.
Well, there's a difference between hate
and freedom of speech. People like this
advocate for this protection, but then
whenever they have a majority, they'll
totally oppress the people that are
around them. Do you have any evidence
for that? Do you have any evidence for
that? You just made a statement. Do you
have any evidence that when they were a
majority, we start oppressing contrary
that when the Prophet Muhammad, peace be
upon him, became the majority and power
and took over the Kaaba, yes, with the
pagan Arabs, we said, "Today is a day of
mercy." They were a majority. And when
Muslims were majority, where you
Christians were persecuting and killing
the Jews, real, uh, anti-Semite, the
Jews were running to Muslim lands for
safety. What he's doing is hate.
He's not That's a in a hate crime, man.
He's going fully against another another
religion. He's If you're going against
our religion is a hate crime.
And this is Islam. This is what you're
talking about. This is a Muslim area.
This is a Muslim area.
Oh, okay. Oh, hold on a second. One
second. Did you guys hear that? He is
insulting the Prophet Muhammad, peace be
upon him. So, he wasn't just preaching
there, was he, Asmongold, you [__] I
challenge you to a debate. How about
that, you coward? Yeah, you can stay in
your mom's basement. Okay. All right,
you can stay in your flipping mom's
basement, yeah? You coward. So, it
wasn't him going there and just
preaching about the boss gospel, Jesus
dying for the sins, and whatever
whatever. No Muslim would have an issue
with that and I You know one gives a
damn. Christianity is the least of our
concern, with all due respect, okay?
People Christian to [__] to Islam.
They He was insulting the Prophet
Muhammad. Now, imagine, like in the
movie Die Hard, if I'm not mistaken,
when uh What's his name?
Bruce Willis went to a predominantly
black area and used the word N. The
N-word. N I G G A.
What do you think is going to happen to
him? If I go to a predominantly white
area, Christian Bible Belt,
and say,
I'll give you an example, "Fuck Jesus."
What do you think is going to happen to
you? Am I going to come and say, "I'm
just preaching about Islam or whatever,
and they just hate me because of that."
No, you are a liar. You've just proven
that he has nothing to do with him
preaching, but rather him insulting the
Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him. You
coward.
Yeah, just get the [__] out of here,
exactly. Problem solved.
But excuse me, Mr. We live here. So, so
if we came outside this
No, but at the end of the day, this is
our community.
You don't see any of our You don't see
Muslims walking around insulting other
faiths. Ah, there's the key there. And
that's true. Do you see us Muslims
walking around insulting Jesus or Moses,
which are prophets anyway, but insulting
the Jews for being Jews and the
Christians for being Christians and the
Hindus for being Hindus or the Sikhs for
being Sikhs or an atheist for being
atheist. No. So, you see, Asmongold,
you're a coward. And I challenge you to
a debate, you absolute [__] You can
clearly see that you are lying. You are
purposefully lying knowing that that man
was there not preaching, rather
insulting. And that's what riled up
these Muslims. Where is Ramadan? We're
fasting. Okay, we're not going to go and
just just cuz someone's preaching the
Quran we can't deal with that Jesus is
God, the most illogical thing you can
ever believe in, that God became a man.
Carry on preaching all day every day.
But he's doing that
>> You guys can preach about your religion
the same But he's not preaching. He's
inciting hatred by saying he did he he
was calling our prophet a donkey.
What do you mean he's not? Like he's
What do you mean he's not? The officer
I'm sorry, sir, but here you're wrong.
You wasn't in there when he was
insulting. So, what do you mean he's
not? That's the issue there. The issue
is not him preaching his religion, it's
about him insulting the Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him. This
ideology is just totally incompatible
with Western values and Western culture.
>> Can you imagine? It is incompatible
incompatible with Western values and
Western culture.
He just said that he was calling the
Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon a
donkey. He's the donkey himself. He's
the biggest donkey. He's talking about
donkey. I mean, if you go to the Bible
in Ezekiel, it talks about the emissions
of a donkey, you know, and it talks
about pornography stuff and the prophet
sleeping with their daughters and all
this kind of filth and dirt, uh, you
know, and take the little girls for
yourself, etc. So, the Bible is clear
that Now this guy is saying that it's
goes against Western values.
So, what's what values are you talking
about? Yes, the double standards you
have, the hypocrisy when it comes to
freedom of speech. You can insult the
Muslims, but you can't insult the the
Jews or you can't insult any other
faith, but the Muslims it's fine. So,
what values are you talking about? Yes?
And what paradigm is your values on?
Western values? Christian values? What
values, man? What values are you talking
about that it goes against? Go to any
group of people, to their area, and
insult them, you will get the same
reaction. So, why are Muslims made to be
as if they're doing something ajib or
strange? Yes? It's basic human
psychology that if you go and insult the
black people, you get attacked. If you
go and insult the Christians, you get
attacked. If you insult the Jews, you
get a reaction. It is normal behavior.
>> People are afraid to say this, but I
think this needs to be said. In the same
way that you shouldn't be going over to
Saudi Arabia and telling all the
Muslims, you need to let women, you need
to let them wear, you need to let them
wear this. They also need to not come
over here and tell us, you need to stop
doing this, you need to start doing
this. These two ideologies and ways of
life are completely incompatible.
>> saying this is a Muslim area. No, this
is England. Yeah, exactly, right? And
this is what they try and do. They try
to take over areas, then they try to
enforce their own laws into that. No,
this is amazing. I I Yeah, total [__]
patriot. I love to see this. Absolutely.
>> So, you're talking about this is
England, but so are those people not
British? Oh, you don't see them as
British. So, they are not British
because they are a different color. You
can see the racism in your tone. And
you're talking about Oh, we don't If we
go to Saudi and tell them Who has come
there? Do you feel those people there
like we're protesting that woman should
not
dress up wearing mini skirts or stop
drinking alcohol? They don't care. This
is your country. Well, what about our
country? You can do whatever you You
have your cultural values. No problem.
When a British person, and we have many
of those British women becoming Muslims,
what are you going to tell them? They
are not following What What values are
they following? The values that God
gave. So, you're acting as if they're
protesting and saying we don't want no
more pubs, we don't want no more this or
that. We want women to dress up in
hijabs. That's not the case, and you
know that very well. You know you're
lying. And that woman is not a patriot.
She's speaking sense. But obviously she
wasn't informed that that man was
insulting the Prophet Muhammad. Peace be
upon him. And that's what it is. So, if
you are true to your
cause and you believe this was I think I
I challenge you to debate. Yeah, let's
debate this matter and let's see if you
was to go to any other area and behave
the same way and insult them that you
would have a reaction people clapping
for you and saying, "Yeah, fantastic.
Carry on insulting us." You're an
absolute [__] That's what you are.
Brothers and sisters, till next time.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. This is the new Sadaqa Jariya
in town. We are teaching people how to
pray. And every time they pray, you get
to share in that reward. And when they
teach their children and their
children's children
the reward continues. Every Fajr Dhuhr
Asr
>> Maghrib Isha Tarawih Tahajjud [music]
Every recitation you share in the
reward. For just £100 you can help teach
20 to 60 people.
>> Like me. Learn how to pray salah. Donate
today. Donate today. Donate today.